I found this thing.
And when I moved
outwards, and breathed.
[MUTTERING]
Every time I did that, I was
centered in the character
and I knew what I
was doing and I knew
where I was and I was moved.
I'm going to give you the
actor director's perspective,
applying my 50 years in the
film industry to your movies.
You're going to experience
the way that I like
to work with a screenwriter.
So I reached out to my
good friend Scott Frank,
and we will be
looking at character.
We'll be looking at structure,
we'll be looking at tone.
I really love how you just
smashed into that flashback.
It feels right.
There's a lot of lines that
you could do with looks.
Right.
The second line to the bottom,
I would add for f**** sake
to give her a little attitude.
When you act and direct
at the same time,
it's a balancing act.
Actors tend to
focus on the moment,
but directors have
to do more than that.
Action.
The director is the leader.
You're never going to
know every single thing
that your crew member knows.
But what you do have to have is
a unifying language of vision.
As a leader, you have
to make a decision,
and then support that decision.
Good. cut.
But it's important that
you know that you're going
to be filled with anxiety.
What is this movie going to be?
How should I redo the script?
Is it going to be OK?
You have to learn to trust
that you will be inspired.
And what I've come to learn
is that eventually, I'll
be standing there
and it will come.
That's something that
took a long time to learn.
The truth is, is that
everything that you have to know
is inside of you.
Every decision-making
process is instinctual.
It can come from
within, and as long
as you have a pen and a
paper to write it down,
you're in good shape.
I'm Jodie Foster, and
this is my MasterClass.